SO NOW DONALD TRUMP HAS TWO
BLACK FRIENDS.
HE HAS -- I HOPE BEN CARSON
DOESN'T GET JEALOUS.
>> Sean: JOINING US RIGHT NOW,
DARRELL PARKS AND CANDICE OWENS
IS IN THE STUDIO.
SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
YOU ACTUALLY ARE PART OF THIS
STORY.
KANYE FIRST OFFENDED YOU.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
APPARENTLY IT WAS MY BRAIN THAT
LAUNCHED THIS IDEALOGICAL CIVIL
WAR IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
I'M SO EXCITED ABOUT IT.
THIS IS A TREMENDOUS TIME TO BE
ALIVE AS A BLACK AMERICAN.
LIES THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
ORCHESTRATED BECAUSE THEY
CONSIDER US A LOW INFORMATION
VOTER MARKET.
SO THEY THINK WE'RE NOT GOING TO
RESEARCH THE STATS AND NEVER
FIND OUT.
>> Sean: THE RACE CARD IS PLAYED
EVERY YEAR.
DRIVES ME NUTS.
14 STATES, DARRELL, NOW HAVE
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT, REGARD
LOW.
BLACK AMERICANS RECORD LOW.
HISPANIC AMERICANS, RECORD LOW.
WOMEN IN AMERICA, RECORD LOW.
UNEMPLOYMENT RECORDS, THAT IS
SINCE DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IS THAT GOOD FOR AMERICA?
OBAMA HAD EIGHT YEARS, 13
MILLION MORE AMERICANS OR FOOD
STAMPS.
EIGHT MORE MILLION AMERICANS IN
POVERTY.
THAT'S HIS LEGACY.
WHO IS DOING A BETTER JOB?
WHO?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T KNOW
HOW TRUMP CAN TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
PROGRESS.
THAT STILL DOESN'T DEAL WITH THE
REAL ISSUE.
THE REAL ISSUE IS BLACK
AMERICANS ARE STILL HAVING GREAT
DIFFICULTY --
>> Sean: I WON'T STOP UNTIL
EVERY MAN AND WOMAN HAS A LIFE
AND TRAJECTORY AND JOB.
DID OBAMA FAIL WITH 13 MILLION
ON FOOD STAMPS?
>> HE DIDN'T FAIL AT ALL.
HE MADE BLACK AMERICA A FOCUS.
WHAT I WANT TO SEE IS PRESIDENT
TRUMP SHOW US THAT BLACK AMERICA
IS A PRIORITY FOR HIM AND HAVE
SPECIFICS HOW HE PLANS TO DO IT.
>> Sean: COMMENTS.
>> IT'S OKAY.
I LIKE WHEN THEY DO THIS.
JUST ADMIT THAT BLACKS ARE DOING
BETTER UNDER THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
IT'S FINE.
IT'S THIS REFUSAL TO ADMIT IT
AND BLACKS WILL DO THE RESEARCH
AND SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Sean: I HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED.
AL GORE.
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO
COUNT YOU IN THE CENSUS OR THE
CHANGE IN TONE AND CADENCE
BEFORE PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
AMERICAN AUDIENCES.
I ALWAYS FELT IT WAS INSULTING.
BUT THE POLICIES, YOU KNOW --
LOOK AT WHAT KANYE SAID.
4,000 AMERICAN SOULS SLAUGHTERED
IN CHICAGO.
WE ONCE SCROLLED THE NAMES.
WE HEARD ABOUT TRAYVON MARTIN,
WE HEARD ABOUT FERGUSON.
I SCROLLED THE NAMES.
WE NEVER HEARD OF THESE 4,000
PEOPLE SHOT AND KILLED.
>> Sean: BECAUSE CHICAGO IS RUN
BY DEMOCRATS.
THEY NEVER WANT TO HOLD THEIR
MAYOR UP.
4,000.
THAT'S THE EXACT SAME -- ABOUT
THE SAME NUMBER OF AMERICAN THAT
WERE SLAUGHTERED IN THE IRAQ
WAR.
IT'S A WAR ZONE.
TRUMP OFFERED TO SEND THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND THE DEMOCRATS
OPPOSED HIM.
SO WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO, TRUMP
IS TRYING TO BE EFFECTIVE THERE
AND WE HAVE SO MANY GREAT
RESULTS IN BLACK AMERICA --
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
DARRELL?
>> SEAN, LET ME SAY THIS THOUGH.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM MY PRESIDENT
TO TELL US THAT SOMETHING ABOUT
BLACK AMERICA IS A PRIORITY FOR
HIM TOMORROW.
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR HIM FOCUS
ON MENTAL HEALTH, EDUCATION,
HEALTHCARE.
THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT HE CAN
HELP US --
>> Sean: OBAMACARE WORK OUT
GREAT FOR EVERYBODY.
>> I'D DID IT.
>> AND TRUMPS NUMBERS ARE BETTER
AND HE NEEDS MORE TIME IN OFFICE
TO CONTINUE TO DO AN AMAZING
JOB.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE ALMOST ABOARD
THE TRUMP TRAIN.
WORE AGREEING ON SOMETHING HERE.
>> LET ME SAY SOMETHING.
I WANT TO SEE TRUMP BE
SUCCESSFUL.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK HE'S FOCUSING ON
THE ISSUES THAT AFFECT BLACK
AMERICA.
I HOPE HE WOULD.
>> SO YOU MUST AGREE THAT OBAMA
WAS NOT FOCUSING ON THE ISSUES
THAT AFFECTED BLACK AMERICA IF
YOU DON'T THINK TRUMP IS IN.
THE NUMBERS ARE IN AND BLACKS
ARE DOING BETTER UNDER HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> I LOVE PRESIDENT OBAMA.
WE SHOULDN'T SPEND MORE TIME
PUTTING HIM DOWN.
>> IT'S TIME TO SHOW THAT THINGS
ARE DIFFERENT.
FOR SO LONG THEY HAVE TOLD US
BECAUSE THERE WAS A BLACK
PROGRESSMENT PROGRESS.
PROGRESS IS NOT A SKIN TONE.
PROGRESS IS A NUMBER.
FOR SO LONG WE'VE BEEN
CONVINCED, LOOK, HE'S TAKING A
PHOTO OPEN WITH BEYONCE AND
JAY Z.
THAT MEANS NOTHING.
CHICAGO GOT WORSE WHILE OBAMA
WAS IN OFFICE AND HE CAME FROM
THERE.
YOU CAN'T DISPUTE THE FACTS
HERE.
>> Sean: IS THIS CULTURAL SHIFT?
>> WE'RE ON THE BRINK OF IT AND
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S GOING TO BE
AMAZING TO WATCH.
I'M SO HAPPY THAT IT STARTS WITH
A SINGLE TWEET.
I DID PREDICT IT.
KANYE WEST IS THE FIRST.
>> Sean: WHEN I INTERVIEWED YOU
EARLIER IN THE WEEK.
IT'S GOING TO BE FUN TO WATCH
YOU TRAJECTORY.